[Music]
to our other top story take a look at
this video a parent facing charges of
child abuse and neglect after allegedly
helping his son beat up another child
thank you for joining us at four I'm
Kirsten joy and I'm Brian Loftis 39 year
old Jose Montez is behind bars after
turning himself in this morning over at
the Clark County Detention Center eight
news now's Laura negretti talks to the
child's mother
what started off as a fight between two
kids ended with a man hitting and
kicking the other right here
Clark County School District police say
Jose Montez faces charges of child abuse
and Battery accused of letting his son
fight and then joining in the fight
happened Wednesday April 14th around two
in the afternoon near delh Robison
Middle School the kid he's shown hitting
is a 13 year old his mother Melissa
Rodriguez heartbroken decisuit just
grabbed my son and smashed him towards
that fence and that sidewalk right there
it's
just to see this area right now and
knowing my son was like they're
defensive and not having anybody help
him until towards the end
it's not fair police say this video
shows Montez kicking the teen she took
to social media for justice and now
hearing of his arrest that is the best
news I've ever received
after two trips to the hospital she says
her son is recuperating with
concussion-like symptoms I'm just
thanking God at this moment that my son
is not dead because one one wrong kick
towards the head it could kill somebody